also I'm wearing flats and if you know
my mother that's like so controversial
in our family
but I've chosen to not
because I thought I made the whole
dress more
casual Aoki Lee Simmons calling out mom
Kimora as she rocks flats for her
graduation from Harvard shout out Aoki
she's my feisty one I always say YouTube
feisty Aoki you better watch it and
ahead of ioky's big day she clearly had
food on the brain risking running late
to the ceremony coming okay I will be at
graduation in a minute I was waiting for
my IHOP it is here now and you know the
opening speeches can get you know I'll
I'll watch them online but what I will
not do is not get my pancake I can hear
the income in your late music well she
arrived in the nick of time and even
shared the inspo behind her graduation
look but the look is eating the beach
dress is Beach dressing all things are
great fun buttons in the back but we do
not care I am getting a Classics degree
which is like Greek mythology so I am
dressed
on theme it was trying to give Greek
goddess because I wrote my last paper on
I'm a Greek Queen it makes me feel so
proud Kimora posted a photo from the
crowd writing you did it and Mom is so
so proud of you she understands how
other people feel and she understands
how she's perceived and I think that all
of these things just make for a
well-rounded like person it sets the
stage for her for her future in such an
amazing Way Big Sis Ming Lee even
captured Aoki running back after to
embrace her family Ming Lee celebrated
her own graduation from NYU last week of
course Kimura shared pics from the big
day with the caption we did it my first
baby graduated college
it's been a journey and a labor of love
but you did it my okay and me and
they're in college and they're doing
their their thing
ayoki is really hardcore into modeling
whereas meaning I think is a little bit
more of an influencer type less a
straightforward model